das land
entnazifizierung das ist putins kriegs
vorwand entnazifizierung ein land dessen
präsident jude ist in dem juden kämpfen
gegen putin sowie ashoka ski und sein
sohn david seit dem ersten kriegstag
organisieren sie die verteidigung ihrer
stadt nico im südosten der ukraine mit
reporter philipp potthoff hat mit ihm
gesprochen
sie sind religiöse juden ukraine vater
und sohn und sie dienen zusammen in den
ukrainischen streitkräfte um irland
gegen die russischen invasoren zu
verteidigen das kreml diktator putin
irland entnazifizierung will darüber
können vater und sein sohn david die in
der ostukrainischen stadt mir pro leben
nur bitter lachen ascha leistete in der
sowjetunion seinen wehrdienst ab kämpfte
2014 gegen pro-russische separatisten im
osten der ukraine als der krieg begann
war für ihn klar dass er sich wieder bei
der armee melden wird seinem sohn wollte
er das eigentlich ersparen doch david
wollte dienen an der seite seines vaters
unterstütze das ist mal was bedeutet es
für sie dass sie neben ihrem sohn stehen
und zusammen dienen
für mich heißt das dass ich einen echten
menschen erzogen habe eigentlich wollte
ich dass er seine pläne wahr macht sein
studium beendet und dann nach israel
ausgewandert um dort in der armee zu
denen dort eine militärische karriere zu
machen
aber seit beginn des krieges hat dann
nicht mehr auf mich gehört egal was ich
gesagt habe ich habe ihm gesagt dass ich
hier für uns beide arbeiten werde aber
er hat seine entscheidung getroffen er
ist ein erwachsener mensch und bis
entscheidung gefällt mir
weil ich der sohn meines vaters bin mein
vater hat schon 2014 mich meine freunde
meine familie unser land verteidigt wie
könnte ich eine andere entscheidung
treffen
mich hat niemand gezwungen das zu tun am
ersten tag des krieges hast du mich um 5
uhr geweckt dabei alarm ich habe gleich
verstanden dass der krieg begonnen hat
noch blieb mir pro von einer großen
russischen offensive verschont doch
immer wieder gibt es raketenangriffe auf
die stadt russische spezialeinheiten
versuchen nach pro einzudringen und die
stadt für eine mögliche invasion
auszukundschaften
vater und sohn david arbeiten jeden tag
dafür um die russischen pläne zu
durchkreuzen
sie dienen zusammen und sie beten auch
zusammen ihr glaube gibt ihnen kraft
diesen krieg durchzustehen doch auch sie
sind von der brutalität der russischen
truppen schockiert
was denken sie wenn sie das sehen
das ist ein großer schmerz der schmerz
unseres volkes und hass auf jene die das
begangen haben die russen sind tiere
für usher ist klar sie kämpfen nicht nur
gegen putin sondern gegen eine armee von
barbaren
das ist nicht putin r schießt ist nicht
gut in der seine armee nachschub liefert
putin richtet seine geschütze auch nicht
auf die städte wo unsere bürger
friedlich neben putin drückt nicht auf
den knopf um eine rakete auf das
krankenhaus in mario pohl oder dem
flughafen in den ebro zu feuern das
macht nicht putin sondern die bürger der
russischen föderation
sie tun es offenbar mit großer freude
[Musik]
das cri wir uns jetzt zugeschaltet
philipp fiat offen dieser beitrag stammt
philipp das narrativ der
entnazifizierung der ukraine ein leben
klammert sich gut ihn ja weiterhin fest
wie ist das überhaupt entstanden und mit
welchen mitteln versucht er das auch
weiterhin in die welt zu verbreiten
putin hat sich für dieses namens
entschieden als 2014 hier die revolution
in der ukraine stattgefunden hat er
verstanden hat dass die ukraine jetzt
richtung nato richtung europa will und
er das verhindern muss und er hat sich
schon dieses nazi nach aktiv entschieden
dass von anfang an komplett absurd war
weil es etwas auslöst bei den russen
weil das funktioniert denn der kampf
gegen die nazis im zweiten weltkrieg das
ist bis heute sehr identitätsstiftend in
russland es funktioniert das
funktioniert auch emotional bei den
russen das kommt an und wenn man sich
jetzt die kriegspropaganda anschaut wie
junge müssen motiviert werden in den
krieg zu ziehen dann heißt es immer tut
es euren großeltern gleich und befreit
wobei ein zweites mal und den nazis
unglaublich erzählt uns einmal gerade wo
du dich befindest die situation hinter
dir wir sehen menschen dort mit dem
fahrrad vorbei fahren das sind immer
bilder die einen kurz aufatmen lassen in
diesen krieg das ist immerhin noch orte
gibt wo eine art kriegsalltag
ja ich bin hier in wer ist das ist die
heimatstadt von kleines präsident
selensky und wie in den meisten städten
hat man sich daran gewöhnt dass die
franz war relativ nah ist aber man macht
trotzdem weiter was soll man auch
anderes machen die menschen können sich
ja nicht die ganze zeit in
luftschutzkellern verstecken sie können
auch nicht alle ihm diese stadt ist
natürlich gesichert sowie alle städte in
der ukraine sind überall check point man
hört hier zum einer explosion die
meistens weiter weg stattfinden bei
heute boden auf ziele innerhalb der
stadt attackiert aber ja den menschen
machen natürlich weiter und sie sind auf
das schlimmste gefasst
für peter vielen herzlichen dank für
deine information